You can imagine that whatever
classical state is stored in Y gets XOR'd onto the Qubit X.
And just in the interest of clarity, here's the diagram that
shows the action of this gate on standard basis states,
where we assume the A
and B are binary values.
For other states, the action is determined
by linearity as always.
Now, before we go any further, it will be helpful to
explicitly state a convention that we're going to follow concerning how Qubits are ordered
in quantum circuit diagrams like this one.
And the convention is that
bottom to top ordering in a quantum circuit diagram is equivalent to left to right ordering
as in a tuple or a tensor product.
That's a convention we'll
follow in the series and it's also the convention
that's used in Qiskit.
So for this particular circuit right here, we're thinking about it as
acting on a pair of Qubits X, Y,
X comes first because it's on the bottom, and Y comes last or second in this case, because it's on the top.
The way you can think about
this visually, in case it helps, is to imagine rotating
this circuit clockwise so that the inputs are on the top
and the outputs are on the bottom, and the ordering of the
Qubits will be correct.
Sometimes this ordering trips people up, so just be sure to keep
this convention in mind.
So when we think about the action that this circuit describes, what we have first is a
Hadamard gate applied to Y
and then a Controlled NOT
gate on the two Qubits with Y being the control
and X being the target.
If we wanna write down a unitary matrix that describes the combined
action of these two gates, we can do that.
First, we consider the Hadamard gate on Y.
We're applying the Hadamard gate to Y and doing nothing to X, which is equivalent to
performing an identity operation on X.
And so the action of the Hadamard gate on both Qubits together is
given by the tensor product of the identity matrix and
the matrix representing
the Hadamard operation on Y.
That looks like this, keeping in mind our
convention that X comes first and Y comes second, so it's
the identity tensored with H.
Then we apply the
Controlled NOT operation, which has this matrix
representation, and again, that's consistent with our convention.
The second Qubit Y is the control and the first Qubit X is the target.
Don't be afraid to pause the video and verify that this makes sense and I'll stop reminding you about that.
You can pause these videos, go back and watch parts
as many times as you want, adjust the playback speed if you choose, use them in whatever
way works best for you.
Anyway, when we compose the
two operations together, the combined action is described
by this product right here,
and these two matrices are
multiplied in this order because the Hadamard is performed first and the Controlled NOT
is performed second,
and once again, this is consistent
with what we talked about in lesson one where the ordering
essentially gets reversed.
If we perform the matrix multiplication, we get this matrix right here.
And we can now read off from this matrix what the circuit does to
standard basis states.
If we run the circuit on the input 0, 0, meaning Ket 0 for the first Qubit, Ket 0 for the second Qubit,
the result is the Phi+ Bell state, which we can see from the
first column of the matrix.
If we feed in 0, 1, we get the Phi- state, one zero gives us the Si+ state,
and 1, 1 gives us not Psi-, but -1 X Psi-.
The minus sign isn't
really significant here. If you didn't want this to be here, you could perform a swap
operation on the two Qubits
to get rid of it and you
wouldn't mess up what happened to the first three standard basis states.
But it's really not important
for the sake of this example.
So in summary, the circuit has this action right here on standard basis states.
When you're thinking about
what a particular circuit does, you don't need to go through
the conversion to matrices and multiply them together,
you can also trace through the
action that the circuit has on particular states, and in many cases this will
be the preferred option.
In this example, for instance, we can see what the circuit
does to the 0, 0 state by examining the action of the gates.
The initial state, which
we've named Pi zero here, just to avoid a name
that would be confusing with the Bell states is 0, 0.
We apply the Hadamard gate and the state we get is 0+ which we can expand out like this,
and then the Controlled NOT operation takes this state to the Phi+ state, which we can see by thinking
about the action that the Controlled NOT has on
standard basis states,
And you can do the same
thing for the other three standard basis states or any
other state for that matter.
We can also incorporate classical bits into quantum circuit diagrams.
They're indicated by
double lines like you see in this diagram.
That is A and B are classical bits and X and Y are Qubits.